ah
hola hola que tal como están
[Aplausos]
a ver yo tengo una pregunta antes de
empezar ha habido algún momento de su
vida donde se han tenido que parar
y hacerse la siguiente pregunta
en el nombre del cielo que estoy
haciendo y esto es muy famosa no sé si
se acuerdan pero esta pregunta se la
hizo el coyote muy seguido vean
y es que a cuántos de nosotros nos ha
pasado eso cuantos no nos hemos detenido
y hemos pensado qué es lo que estamos
haciendo y es que pasa muy seguido la
verdad es que hay momentos que uno ve
que el tiempo pasa que uno está haciendo
las cosas y que pues no sabes si lo
estás haciendo bien o mal o no tal vez
lo que estamos estudiando no nos gusta
tal vez pensamos que nos íbamos a casar
y aún no nos hemos casado tal vez
sigamos viviendo en casa de nuestros
papás y allí es cuando dices sin qué es
lo que está pasando con mi vida y en
esos momentos es cuando uno se pone
nostálgico y voltea con el
'todopoderoso' y le dice no seas malo
mándame una máquina del tiempo no para
regresar y volver a empezar y aquí es
cuando empiezan las preguntas porque si
pudiéramos tener una máquina una máquina
del tiempo siempre queremos volver al
pasado porque porque no nos damos la
oportunidad de ir al futuro para ver qué
es lo que hicimos de nuestros errores
para ver si aprendimos la lección porque
de nada sirve si vas a volver a llegar a
ser un error y volver a estar en el
mismo error que hiciste y otra vez y
tener que subirte
a la máquina para regresar entonces eso
es antes que nada me presento porque aún
solicito comunica desafortunadamente yo
soy de equipos reno
soy parte de una gran gran empresa que
se llama máquina 501 es tan grande esta
empresa que me permite estar aquí con
ustedes platicándole lo que los errores
que yo he hecho y que esta empresa me
permite hacerlos ver que es un acierto y
les bato la de platicar el primer error
que este error si no es mío hay que
culpar a alguien más siempre me y nos
pasaba el otro la que estábamos grabando
la edad una de nuestras producciones
porque a los 18 años nos piden que
definamos qué es lo que vamos a estudiar
para toda nuestra vida a ver el promedio
de edad en méxico es de 76 años ustedes
quieren el país quieren nuestros papás
quieren nosotros mismos nos exigimos que
a los 18 años sepamos que vamos a hacer
las próximas tres cuartas partes de
nuestra vida ustedes creen que estamos
capaces para eso porque cuando miramos
economía paso yo lo primero que pensé
fue a si yo quiero tener mi futuro y por
futuro me referí a dinero no a 18 años
que otra cosa podemos pensar que no sea
dinero que queremos salir adelante que
queremos independizarnos y la verdad es
que tomamos decisiones pensando
en el dinero que es la carrera que me va
a dejar más realmente le estoy
platicando el 2000 tengo 34 años esta
decisión fue por allá por 1999 por el
2000 y obviamente pues está de moda una
carrera que se llama ingeniería
mecatrónica ingeniería mecatrónica todo
puede salir bien o sea es mecánica
robótica electrónica este computadoras
por supuesto que por ahí va del futuro y
ya después de que convencí a mis papás
que me dieran la oportunidad de irme
estudiar a monterrey al tec de monterrey
a esta nueva carrera a los 3 años me di
cuenta de dos cosas la primera
es que el voltaje es lo que da el
cosquilleo cuando esta gran la
electricidad
y lo segundo es que lo que quema es el
amperaje
y la segunda cosa que me di cuenta es
que hace que mis papás me van a matar
porque después de tres años de estudiar
ingeniería no me gusta no me veo en este
mundo porque porque tome una decisión
pensando en el futuro y en ese entonces
era el error más grave que yo he hecho
en mi vida y de verdad que dije dios mío
qué estoy haciendo al igual que el
coyote dije que me está pasando cómo le
va decir a mis papás afortunadamente no
me fue tan mal y una de las dos cosas
que yo creía estaba mal la electricidad
si es cierta es así es así no la agarren
es así o sea no lo intenten en lo que me
equivoqué es que mis papás me van a
matar porque siempre creímos que es el
error más grande de nuestra vida y es el
error más grande de nuestra vida ustedes
van a ver que en esta plática cuántas
veces he hecho el error más grande de mi
vida y pues bueno después de volver a
tener confianza en mí después de volver
a pensar en qué es lo que me gustaba me
puse a ver qué es lo que me gustaba
me encantaba leer me encantaba estar en
contacto con el entorno estábamos
hablando del 2000 ya empezaba en
internet
todo todo esto todo era favor yo dije
esta maravillosa cosa que es el internet
está logrando borrar las fronteras
entonces nosotros vivimos en mexico el
internet es una realidad voy a estudiar
relaciones internacionales
o sea porque es el futuro nosotros
vivimos estamos en méxico y estamos en
este vivimos en méxico que puede salir
mal está eeuu en sí de nosotros es el
futuro de las relaciones internacionales
no de haber salido esta foto se imaginen
estos años con estas relaciones
internacionales pero bueno eso fue lo
que pasó y tuve la oportunidad de irme a
la ciudad de mexico y estudiar
relaciones internacionales porque luego
había como esta discusión de uno de los
ingenieros son los que ganan dinero los
licenciados no en el país todos somos
licenciados es lo que nos dicen en el
país está ahí
en el país todos somos licencia
todos somos licenciados entonces me fui
esto era méxico y la verdad que me
encontré mi vocación y que me encanta
leer me encanta estar aquí qué bueno que
tuve el error de mi vida qué bueno que
me equivoqué de de carrera qué bueno que
me dieron esta oportunidad este todo mi
entorno para volverlo a hacer el error
de mi vida ya no parecer más el error
más grande que había tenido entonces
llegando a la ciudad de mexico
empiezo a estudiar me encanta y pasa
algo que nunca me imaginé tuve la
oportunidad de empezar a trabajar
en el teatro por necesidad los discos de
hecho viene alguna vez a puebla con una
obra que se llama del graduado y yo era
que vendía los discos vende a los venid
venid a las playeras y me encantaba lo
que hacía y lo después vino otra vez al
entonces era el siglo 21 me parece que
el teatro con una obra que se llamaba
cabaret y la verdad es que estabas
viviendo el sueño podía ir a comprar
medias y maquillaje sin que nadie me
dijera nada pero si en el 2000 estamos
hablando ya del 2007 si yo hubiera
hablado si esta máquina el tiempo que
les desde el principio existiera y
viniera ricky del 2000 a hablar con el
friki del 2007 y le iba nosotros estamos
estudiando relaciones internacionales y
compras maquillaje y medias
te está yendo bien sí ahí vamos no ahí
vamos entonces la vez que fue una de las
experiencias más agradables sobre todo
porque me permitió seguir viajando por
el país por méxico me encanta méxico
yo soy de chihuahua por si no lo había
notado
y ahorita estoy en puebla y vivo en
méxico y estudié en monterrey y tenía la
oportunidad de dar por todos lados en
camión
la gira de estas obras de teatro me subí
al camión y me llevan a todos lados
entonces la pasaba muy muy bien
entonces la vez que ya todo está bien y
aparte empezará algo mágico un momento
mágico musical que se llamaban las redes
sociales pero no estamos hablando del
facebook ni twitter ni estamos hablando
del high five de limewire de esto que
nos permitirá descargar música y la vez
que me di cuenta que pasaba todo el
tiempo todo el tiempo que no estaba
trabajando me la pasaba esté viendo
myspace ligando en haifa que se podía no
tanto pero se podía y entonces me di
cuenta lo mucho que me gustaba me
gustaba internet no porque hay fotones
isa en que mi país es méxico y lo amo
pero mi patria es internet y me quiero
dedicar a esto ya ver ya tengo
relaciones internacionales ya sé que la
electricidad me da miedo ya me gusta el
internet y no pues vamos a dedicarnos a
esto y obviamente era el 2000 estaban
todos los portales subiendo y tú sigues
trabaja en un portal
de bodas tener un portal o sea hacia
bodas por internet pero ahí a ver ricky
el 2000 hagamos no nos estamos cercanos
a ya estamos internet y este portal
todavía me dejada seguir viajando y
obviamente este portal era de las
primeras redes sociales que existían de
nicho esto es muy importante estas redes
sociales antes del facebook y
generalmente y lo que hay que empezar a
aprender son estos nichos estas
audiencias estos pequeños círculos que
están viviendo algo ustedes piensen como
audiencia que es lo que consumen a veces
y aquí
y otras veces como cómo han cambiado
está estas preferencias como lo que
consumen hace cinco años
ahorita tan sólo cinco años ya no era ya
no es ya no es nada no se parece a nada
lo que hacían y lo de repente también
les voy a dejar esto para vivir
avanzando es cuántas veces no nos han
dicho las televisoras o los contenidos
que siempre son los mismos entonces
bueno ya con este height que yo tenía la
estaba haciendo en grande solamente uno
se vuelve esta chau
se vuelve prepotente y pues ya me voy a
google google e la bilis de los portales
todos queremos trabajar en google o
todos si decimos es que como me gustaría
trabajar en google el problema es que el
señor google no quiere que todos
trabajan con él es la pequeña diferencia
no a veces tú vas isis hay otras aquí
pero y nunca se va a olvidar ese correo
que en el soviet decía muchas gracias
desde google y la vez que estoy y qué
bonito la verdad lo que me estaban
diciendo es sr
retírese por la puerta de atrás porque
enfrente están los clientes no lo
queremos ver no entonces que estaba
pasando con mi vida
porque si estaba haciendo lo que quería
porque muchas veces lo que te dice no
haz lo que quieres y llegarás a donde tú
quieras no señores no pasa si haces lo
que quieres simplemente por hacer lo que
quieres no vas a llegar a donde quieres
te tienes que preparar y ahí es cuando
yo dije cuando las cosas no pasan te
sientes mal pero cuando las cosas por
las que trabajas y estás empeñado y es
tu sueño no pasan de xávea fracaso y eso
se siente y sabe horrible
pero se puede ingerir se puede tragar y
es con el ig bueno también vamos a
empezar a ver las señales a ver ricky
2000 este tabasco estancias pues ahora
tienes que volver a estudiar y todos
estos whatsapp que nos manda nuestras
tías donde viene piolín sonriendo y trae
chispitas y dicen sigue preparando hagan
escaso en las tías algo saben
no no les ponga newt no sean gachos
un año si quieres un año pero ya vamos
con como en el tercer año que metíamos
esos grupos pero bueno vean los no los
echen en la borda disfruten esos glitter
si ya piolín estamo nixon pero bueno
entonces dije vamos a prepararnos
y decidí tomar este reto de hacer una
maestría y zona fácil no es como apz y
no hay que pagarla hay que estudiar
estaba recién casado y me pongo a
estudiar una maestría y esta maestría
era muy muy por muy padre porque me
daban las oportunidades de ir por por
varias universidades del mundo y en una
ocasión me tocó ir a hong kong y otra
vez me pasaron dos cosas se estiran como
siempre pasa dos cosas cuando estoy
estudiando
la primera es que yo bajo un con yo
nunca he leído a asia entonces estaba
fantástico y llegarnos las clases la
edad la edad promedio de la maestría de
50 55 años yo era el más joven de esa
generación en cinco universidades y
llegamos y nos dan la clase un chavo de
20 años con un lamborghini y con 150
millones de dólares en la cuenta y que
no si no estás haciendo bien más agua
sea si te llevas 30 este whistle y no ya
no salió esto y lo segundo que me queda
mucho y que nunca se me olvidará es que
fue lo que él dijo
y él dijo a ver en los 90s nos daba por
incubar empresas en el futuro las
microempresas darle espacio a la gente
para que llegara tuviera su oficina
llegadas al tec y te ponían tu línea
telefónica y te asesorarán después todo
cambió y en los 2000 es llegó está por
la revolución tecnológica los iphones y
un lo que sigue es en incubar apps este
chavo ha ganado tanto unidades dólares
con un jueguito este que muchos ustedes
conocerán entonces este jueguito que él
jugaba así y el bato eran 150 millones
veces ricos más que todos nosotros
entonces
nunca se me olvidará eso porque él dijo
algo muy importante porque nadie está
incubando vídeo
como si ahorita hay una guerra por
cuántos monitores cuantas pantallas
quienes hace más delgadas que nos hacen
más curvas que nos hace tres de todo
mundo está preocupado por que la
pantalla sea increíble pero lo que vamos
a ver en las pantallas porque no estamos
pensando en qué piensan ustedes cuantas
pantallas hay aquí es más piensen en su
casa si tú tienes una computadora y
tienes un celular yo tienes dos
pantallas y si tiene tradición tiene
tres pantallas y si se fijan como no ven
lo mismo en el celular que en la
computadora que en la televisión una
persona consume contenidos totalmente
diferentes y nadie está pensando en eso
dirigen a cara por eso ese bato tiene
150 millones de dólares y yo no no es
porque hizo la app
eso es lo que lo hizo grande que estaba
pensando más allá de nosotros entonces
pues yo regresé muy motivado siguiendo
esto de los portales dije ahora si
google voy por ti éste
pero dije bueno y justamente cuando
regresaba pasa algo que fue este tercer
gran error por allá me adelante en la
foto pero un viejo amigo hacia la nada
me manda un mail y me se oye que estás
haciendo bien necesito verte listo
vamos a echar unas cheves y unas alitas
chávez y unas alitas que puede salir mal
no nunca pensé que iba a ser el tercer
error este es un gran amigo mío que yo
trabajaba con el que nadamos juntos en
el campestre ya saben que los somos de
fuera de la ciudad méxico todos íbamos a
los mismos clubs y inicio y fíjate que
tengo un proyecto que quiero platicarte
este chavo se llama ya lo vieron por ahí
josé manuel torres un viejo amigo mío
muchos años que nos veíamos inicio y
wayne este script tengo un proyecto
fíjense esto tengo un proyecto que
me gusta mucho win pero le he escrito a
televisa tvazteca la reforma el
universal hacen en el desecho que tengo
una idea y naymick y escuchar huila ves
que no estamos ya tan chiquitos ya
estamos creciendo un poquito más me
gustaría
en que te ayudo huevos yo no sé nada de
esto mis enojos es que necesito donde
grabarlo
cuántos estudiantes
hay un local que era una paletería
pues no la están usando voy
qué hacemos es que lo tenemos que hacer
déjame decir a mis papás en cuanto a la
renta y por rentar me significa no me
cobren papas voy a usar
sé lo que está ahí
quiero una paletería y este y entonces
decidimos aventarnos en estos momentos
yo dije ya ya estamos de todos donde
grabar y las cámaras como la escritura
como watts de hecho las cámaras ml como
bat de dónde sacas que youtube por mí yo
y qué hacemos vamos a pensar a quien
conoces pues hay un adicto y siempre se
burla de mis vídeos y según él sabe
editar vamos por él no es como si ya
tenemos un estudio toma nos faltan las
cámaras y quien edite quien grave no
pequeñeces
pero les voy a decir algo en verdad lo
que nos faltaba eran pequeñeces saben
por qué porque tenemos un gran proyecto
tenemos una gran idea había habido del
otro del lado del mundo que alguien
estaba pensando en videos y que se
necesitan nuevos vídeos y nuevos
formatos y nuevas cosas que hacer de
verdad que el dinero eran pequeñeces y
no lo estoy yo porque seamos ricos nada
no no porque pues mezcla tarjeta de
crédito te aguantas 15 meses a que a que
no te hablen pero por eso vas a frenar
tu proyecto a que te adentras los días
del banco a las 7 de la mañana pero por
eso van a frenar su proyecto nos frenen
su proyecto por eso de verdad se los
digo nunca frenen sus cosas por eso por
algo tan insignificante como el dinero
esto es muy importante y volvamos a
víctor dos veces a la semana porque
según él estás en una película no sale
pero lo tenemos que volar porque él
tenía sus compromisos entonces así es
como dijimos guau ya ya ya estamos aquí
ya vamos a empezar a hacerlo vamos a
empezar a grabarlo
y la verdad es que en ese momento
dos cosas me pasaron otra vez
primero actúa quiere decirle a mi esposa
a mis dos hijos que iba a empezar a
hacer youtube
imagínense si hay aquí alguien que es
papá y no hay imagínense como mi hijo te
mandé estudiar canijo para que youtube
está bien
pero youtube es de google
bueno eso youtube es de google
[Aplausos]
y la segunda cosa que nunca pensamos es
porque lo vamos a hacer porque nos gusta
porque queremos estamos gastando nuestro
dinero porque no estamos satisfechos con
lo que estamos viendo porque estoy harto
estábamos hartos en su momento que
tuviéramos que ver todo en inglés el
contenido bueno estaba en inglés porque
aquí sabíamos viendo el chavo del ocho'
34 años después y no escuchaba el 8 este
mal es muy bueno
déjenlo descansar
ya no lo pasearon ahí en el azteca
cuántas veces al pobre señor ya de
muerto pero bueno
sigamos pues lo que nuestro que nosotros
ya estábamos ahí empezamos a ver y la
vez que fue fantástico como a
regañadientes y en contra
pudimos sacar un vídeo el primer vídeo
no trae a micrófono nada pero ya
anunciamos la tercera temporada del
pulso
y es cuando empieza a decir buenos a
iván y llega algo muy padre que es el
primer patrocinador y ojo les platico
esto porque pues una cosa es lo creativo
y otra cosa es el business no que es mi
parte es a mí lo que me preocupa de
máquina
eso es yo hago siempre mi sitio que es
el máquina no por lo aburrido facturas
business plan estamos levantando un
capital unos milloncitos a lo aburrido
cosas significantes pero solo se
alistaba a este patrocinador muy grande
de hecho es una telefónica esa que todo
su territorio es méxico
pero todos sabemos que no todo su
territorio méxico y chihuahua sales de
la carretera hallada o sales de la
ciudad pasa la casita y ya no hay señal
no nos engañemos no todo méxico es
territorio telcel pero es eso eslogan
y hay que respetarlo y cuando te van a
patrocinar lo tienes que respetar
llegamos su marido muy salsas con los
directivos y se nos mira van a tener que
hacer unas unos unos videíto si van a
tener que vender unas tarjetas amigo que
por supuesto señor lo que usted guste
pues tengo este hecho me dicen no coloca
no como porque no digo primero porque
saben algo nuestros contenidos no le
mienten a la audiencia estamos hasta que
nos mientan su empresa no no no es mala
pero no sé todo el territorio
pero hacen cosas muy buenas porque no
recalcamos lo bueno
todos así que ya se negocia tarjeta de
crédito
con estas cámaras en total no se perdió
tanto tenemos salud
y de repente esta empresa y se va va a
haber pues vamos a probar vamos a ver
qué pasa y qué pasó que ha sido una de
las campañas tanto para ellos como para
nosotros más exitosas y ahí fue cuando
aprendí lo segundo
primero el contenido y después el
negocio fíjense qué fuerte aquí es donde
dije primero preocúpate por respetar a
tu audiencia saben quiénes no lo
respetaban los que nos ponían
repeticiones y repeticiones y ahorita
nos dicen que hay que ver los cajeros
del zodiaco otra vez como están en
youtube en el rojo como por qué me voy a
prender la televisión otra vez a ver los
caballeros me encantan los amo pero
porque voy a prender la televisión de
otra vez verán chavo tengo 34 años tengo
34 años que puedo ver en youtube lo que
tú quieras consumiendo game of thrones
series de netflix que están porque ojo
porque no nos respetaban y es cuando hay
que decir sabes que todos los que las
personas que tienen audiencias grandes
en youtube saben porque las tienen
porque lo respetan saben porque lo
respetan porque es porque fue codo a
codo cómo crecieron porque esos batos
agarraron sus audiencias y las empezó a
respetar y leían los comentarios de
youtube es ya eso no me gusta su mail
eso no me gusta ricky no hagan
entrevistas no se vendan
porque todos nos dicen hay es que
censuran nuestra saben cuál es nuestra
mejor censura que lo ve nuestras
familias nuestra mamá ustedes y ustedes
y decimos una mentira
ya se vendieron y eso es como debe ser
todo el contenido no tienes que hablar
de política para respetar tenemos
programas de deportes tenemos programas
que dicen la verdad no los programas
deportología ahorita lo vieron
seguramente para apareció en su facebook
que decían este vídeo de los argentinos
diciendo que el fútbol era malísimo
mexicano lo es pero tampoco ante ellos
es bueno y eso es lo que les dijo
deportología es muy mal nuestro fútbol
pero allá tiene esos grandes equipos son
los aquí tenemos cinco seamos honestos
entonces son esas cosas que empezaron a
empezaron a funcionar y así es como se
hizo máquina 501 a base de escuchar a la
gente de saber qué es lo que está
pasando
y respetarla porque después después
vienen los grandes proyectos porque
cuando pega tu proyecto ahora si se
acuerdan que en resumen hace dos años
haya mandado el mail
ahora sí se nos contestaron oye éste qué
tal si te vienes a esta televisora oa la
otra no más le vamos a cambiar el
formato porque pues no cómo van a salir
cómics en un fondo matarás no estás
hablando de política porque pones un
cómic
como como entonces sí y después de ahí
pues te van a ver más gente no como
estoy una plataforma más grande del
mundo se llama youtube puesto que me dan
más gente
porque porque quiere llegar a cambiar mi
mi mi proyecto porque te quieres adueñar
de él porque eso es lo que hacían y
luego después de ahí uno cae en esta
contradicción barata donde uno dice es
que la televisión está muerta la radio
está muerta los señores
todos de aquí todos los de aquí corrimos
los martes a ver el monólogo de adal
ramones todos porque nos encantaba
porque lo hacía muy bien porque era un
contenido que nosotros no habíamos visto
porque éramos niños porque éramos más
jóvenes porque eso es lo que nos gustaba
la gente se corre a los contenidos si
corremos a verla nexis a las 12 de la
noche maratón de 10 episodios ahorita
están que se desmayan con vemos trans
todos quieren que sea mañana entonces no
se sientan la televisión no se está
muriendo los periódicos no se están
muriendo la radio no está muerta esto es
una mentira y saben que si nosotros que
somos los creadores de contenido ustedes
empezamos a decir lo mismo vamos a ir
igual que ellos cuando en el 2003 ya no
tu proyecto no va a funcionar esa cosa
nadie la va a ver si nosotros pensamos
al igual y no pensamos en esta amplitud
y decir oye no tiene nada de malo claro
que hay que esperar a la novia más
bonita la nueva más bonita en su momento
pues llegó y fue h veo a la casa de
monstruo y ahí es cuando decimos pues
vamos por este proyecto pero sabe porque
se escuche
porque nunca dijeron que querían revisar
el guión nunca te respetamos lo que vas
a hacer es el mismo formato normal no
hables de chile porque en chile en chile
te meten al bote si hablas de política
y lo segundo es la radio cuando llegue
este proyecto somos creadores un
proyecto que se llama laguna estamos en
grupo fórmula estamos entre maxine
woodside lópez dóriga a la hora más
escuchada de su estación y ellos se
dieron la oportunidad de creer en
nosotros porque nos decían así te vamos
a la nueva noche de alan a la noche está
viendo que mostró un sur no quiero
estoy viendo el visito comunica litera
ya sé que le va a fallar bien gacho el
ratito pero si amigo este entonces son
estos medios que se están dando la
oportunidad no estamos peleados con
nadie esto es lo que les quiero
transmitir nos la tele nos está muriendo
no estamos peleados con nadie estamos
peleados con que no respeten a la
audiencia estamos hartos de que no nos
respeten y eso lo que ustedes deben de
hacer si ustedes están si tienen esta
idea de lo que ha de crear contenido
contenido diferente respetan a la
audiencia y segundo como todo vaya de
dos en dos a este no lo hagan por las
vistas
háganlo porque ustedes quieren hacerlo
si usted no les gusta algo que están
haciendo a ver algo tú y hazlo bien y
escribes el guión y pones una paletería
y le prende unas cámaras y le pones unas
luces y vas a ver cómo te va a ir bien
porque hay que estar preparados para
todo inclusive está el coyote cuando le
bajan en la que le van a caer las piezas
saca su paraguas
y bueno ya me tocó porque hay más
errores y todos los que han sido errores
de verdad en su momento que ese
platicado porque va a terminar han sido
los errores más grandes de mi vida y
estoy seguro que va a cometer otros
vienen muchos por delante
pero lo que estoy convencido y muy
agradecido es que yo ya tengo mi máquina
no fue la máquina del tiempo que yo pedí
al principio es una máquina 501 es una
máquina que me permite estar en contacto
con los nuevos contenidos con las nuevas
audiencias haciendo lo que me gusta y
eso es lo que yo vengo invitarlos hagan
si ustedes su propia máquina una máquina
que les funcione que los quiera llevar a
donde están
va a haber errores en el camino
muchísimos pero les digo algo
vale mucho la pena muchísimas gracias
[Música]